nope that's way more
oh no it's on the right side how do i
change that aj
i don't know
no
hey it worked hello
barton teague hey teague i know teague
you're usually in chris is right but
since his internet's down dang it tk
lily lily's fandom mainly marvel
christopher guzman ace world
tanish khanna brian comstock
tk what up
shot what up what up what up what up
what up how's it going everybody
uh i'm gonna change a few things gonna
do this
yeah
uh i don't i don't i don't have any
spoilers for this episode i haven't seen
episode three i've only seen an episode
they only gave us episodes
two and uh
i wanted two to watch
so uh
do we
we'll do a poll
like when it's about to start in like
20 in in 17 minutes
we will do a
poll and we'll see
[Music]
if we want to watch miss marvel first or
if you want to watch obi-wan first i
feel like watching obi-wan first would
be a better idea that way we can avoid
spoilers for it
um because there won't be that many
spoilers
for like because it's the finale for
kenobi right so i feel like we don't
want to like
we don't want to
risk being spoiled the end hey
[Music]
that's
uh no ravi uh i think chris does
uh but no i i don't
no
i don't follow the boys what's up marcus
jones
grass toucher miss marvel
or kyle says miss marvel
uh darren no unfortunately chris's
internet is down
he cannot watch with me right now sadly
gotta go to school in 17 minutes tk dang
oh thanks kyle i mean i i don't know if
i should say
thanks you haven't said if you liked it
or not yet you could say you hated it
uh christopher gizman i don't really
stream anything on
twitch some
yeah
okay brian see brian's uh
brian's uh
uh
saying what i'm i'm thinking even even
if it's like for the people who don't
watch star wars like we still don't want
to like ruined
sue
hello hello
i finished school two hours ago nice
yeah i'm i'm tired too guys this one's
gonna and i go i have to go back to la
tomorrow
um
so uh
huh that's funny matthew do you like
arcane i don't know how i feel about it
like
i
i
i don't like jinx's like story arc
like i just don't like it but
you know
uh shane uh
i couldn't i couldn't do a strange
things review for you because i have not
seen it yet i just haven't seen it yet
i've been meaning to but there's a few
other shows that i have to kind of
i have to finish first
what's going on buck barnes atl oh
that's gotta be joe huh what's up joe
uh mr cosmic strange maxwell how you
doing what's up musa how's it going
how's it going
there you go marcus yeah i usually try
to get my workouts done in the morning
as well
like just because you get it out of the
way like when i was younger i used to
like
really love working out and i would be
in the gym for like two hours and now
i'm just like all right let's get this
workout over with
thank you yo joe tube yojotube thank you
uh yeah
obi-wan's tonight so is miss marvel it
is 12 36 a.m for me right now
um
that's funny
what's up joey p
skywalker club a little worried about
this finale i would really hope it
delivers yeah i'm really hoping so too
laura goose thompson what is going on a
member in the chat owner on your
breakdown you missed two h drags on this
coach of
strike yourself first uh
what what breakdown would that be
uh it is a twice picture and then
wait no
and then that is a black pink
poster they're both posters
twice
black pink
yes sue
am i for real a medic
no
did that come from
i am not no i have no medical training
what so whatsoever no
uh la's good i'm there uh
part time right now but uh
more and more as the weeks go by
um as i work with more studios and stuff
like that um so yeah
what's up matthew arona what's going on
hello hello hello hello tom holland
hello mo
hamod
ah thanks man the marvel hype man i feel
like uh it's about to get even
bigger uh katie avenger what did you
think of eternals personally loved it
it's extremely overheated underrated let
me know your thoughts yeah i liked it i
i really liked i really liked it um i'm
not saying you know it was one of the
greatest movies ever but i did i really
liked it i don't
i don't quite understand the hate that
it got i i think
i think
the reason it got so much hate is
because of one the pacing but also how
it like jumped which is this is part of
the pacing but how it like jumped around
and stuff like that um
you know also skyward club i don't know
if i said thank you for the super chat
but thank you for the super chat um yeah
uh i think just the pacing how it kind
of like jumped around and everything
like that i think that kind of like
it didn't sit well with some people and
i think that's why it got a lot of hate
so
yeah uh my top three mcu movies so far
for shot cut
i don't typically count avengers in game
and infinity war because they're such
big events but you know you can always
throw those top
for those at the top but uh i got thor
ragnarok shang chi
um
captain america civil war
probably
they're the first avengers film the
first there's some ah man there's so
many good ones first avengers film is
always going to be
so epic
so
it's cat in the chair i wonder if i move
no it's my
my fluffy cat she's very fat
yes the rumors are true i am
really a cosmic wonder um i saw
something somebody ask me a question
sue k-pop aficionado uh
i like a lot of groups um
i have more posters but um
uh
i like mamamoo i like stray kids
i like stacy itsy i love
love love love itsy
um
that's it bts obviously
a lot of people love bts even though
they're on a hiatus right now but uh
there's a lot i like solo artists too
like hyolin hyuna
um oh i like asp i was listening to them
i like a lot of different stuff
uh
let's catch up
deadpool where ah i don't know
um i think he's gonna do his own film uh
and i'm starting to think that that's
how it should
be like i'm starting to think that
deadpool should have his own film
and and like
that's that's film is dedicated to him
you know
getting into
our universe hey what's up joshua barton
haven't talked in a bit how's it going
enchantrix what's up
what's going on i you should i i don't
know we should watch first all right
hold on let's do the poll
uh
yeah what's up jake yeah i know
i know it's unfortunate that his stream
is down all right let's uh how do i do
it over here yes i do whatever thank you
for that super chat jay okay so
which show do we
watch first
uh
why is it only giving me yes or no
answer oh okay uh
kenobi
miss marvel
bam
pull
i think
the pull drop pull drop there it is
go ahead vote tom holland i have not
visited india no
no no no i have not yet i do want to
black bolton terrigen missed i
i don't think we're gonna be getting
it's so weird
to talk about the inhumans i heard a
long time ago that the inhumans were
going to be referenced
in miss marvel but as a tv show like
they were a tv show
that
miss marvel watches
no i no idea no idea
uh yeah
i don't yeah i don't i think i think
what they're gonna do with miss marvel
is they're still gonna make it somewhat
like
they're still gonna make it to where
it's like
there's something inside of her and
they've already hinted at this right um
bruno hinted at it in the second episode
where she was wearing the bangle and
he's like the power is not emanated from
the bangle it's emanated like from
inside you it's unlocking the power
inside of you so they're clearly gonna
do some type of like
dna thing like it's in your blood um
and uh
najma who's gonna be the villain she
says and i can't remember what the
trailer was called
seek maybe no i can't remember um but
she
said in the trailer she said something
like you've inherited
greatness or something like that i know
you can't hear it
my cat is snoring and it's pretty funny
yeah
what's going on everybody
galeb abroad jahan i don't know if
you're you're trolling or you really did
hear that miss my episode three release
date changed i don't think it has
otherwise i probably would have heard
about it
are we
i don't even see the poll anymore where
how are we out on the pole
that's pretty dang even
wow
and miss marvel looks like it's pulling
away a little bit i'll tell you what
though guys i bet you miss marvel is
shorter
so
mr anderson if you could be super quick
and deleting spoilers for kenobi
you know once we start watching it i
think we could do miss marvel first
and uh you know let's let's
no let's hope to like cut out all
spoilers and stuff as we watch kenobi
and we can watch it the problem is this
is the final you know what i mean like
it's it's the final do we really want to
risk like
it being spoiled dude i don't know guys
i
do i like chiang chi over black panther
yes i do
i do
uh shang chi is one of my
old all-time top five mcu favorite
movies now like i i really love chongqi
and i have a big connection to it
um because i met a lot of the cast um
see me leo
uh
monger uh
jimmy like i met
a lot of the cast actually another thing
i interviewed the director i interviewed
follow chen who played shanxi's mother
uh i mean
it so it's a it's a close movie to me
but
just speaking of just the movie i i
truly truly did love the movie
truly did
yeah i saw that craven is a
animal lover now the dark avenger i i i
saw that that he doesn't you know
which is kind of funny craving the
hunter but uh he just hunts people i
guess
you know
uh matthew arona yeah i think i think
krazynski is going to be the 616
reed richards so
yeah let's so guys if we can agree i
mean i don't think anyone in here is
going to spoil anything about kenobi
because we're all going to we'll watch
miss marvel
but we'll have to watch out for the
spoilers right
so
uh which is my favorite marvel disney
plus to date loki all day i freaking
i freaking love loki
and i just got the rewatch with my
brother
so good
that
final the finale of of of
loki is like
where we meet he who remains you know
slash kane the conqueror and he's
talking about you know just everything
and he's like
you know if you think i'm evil
wait till you see my variance and he's
like i
i harnessed like goliath and i
weaponized it and i ended the
multiversal war he's like i ended i
ended the multi and like that whole
scene
just that whole fun this is the whole
finale is just amazing i love
i really really love
that serious
huh do i know why the last episode isn't
out yet of uh comes out like three
minutes and you know what guys really
quick i'm just gonna
turn my ac down because it's pretty hot
in here am i wireless i am wireless one
second
rocket everybody thinks you're really
cute
everybody thinks you're really cute go
back to sleep
little rocket
all right guys it looks like um marvel's
taking it
a lot of people are saying this mid
stuff like brent abba one division mid
does that just mean that
it's okay like it's
middle it's like in the middle it's okay
is that what that means
episode two i was thinking that the
grandma was running from
would be involved in the first thing
captain america and ron is a cree they
changed ron for
amy strike you know i thought about that
i i like got major aim vibes like i
really like i really did i got major aim
vibes from uh
uh
miss marvel uh the dodc at the end i i
really did and i'm just sitting there
like
can you show us your best attempt at the
gritty i
thank you for that super chat i have no
idea what that means
ah jonathan that's really funny
i appreciate that super chat tkd man i
just don't know what it means i'm sorry
i really don't
um so
it looks like we're gonna watch miss
marvel first
i i do ask if you
if you leave the stream to watch kenobi
first and you come back in please don't
spoil anything because it's the finale
we really don't want it spoiled
and
uh miss marvel is going to be shorter
than kenobi well let's see um
no not youtube disney plus there it is
oh no i just got a new pc so i have to
log in and this is going to ask me for
password
let's see if we can get it first try
first try
i'm a champion
i can't tell you how many freaking
passwords i have
wait a second
oh
i saw something
beyond infinity i thought uh
i thought lightyear was already out on
disney plus i was like what oh it's a
dance oh thank you for another super
chat tk i i don't know what that is i'm
really sorry
uh uh i i'm sorry uh
i could gregory
but then i want to have all my awesome
lights that elgato gave to me you're
about to know how that feels
all right it's 12 50. miss marble
episode 3 is out it is 48 minutes
um
let's take a look out at how long kenobi
is
are the rumors true nope it's only 52
minutes it's not an hour and a half
all right but it looks like
oh aj you're still here
hello hi aj
hey limitless
oh thank you so much
i appreciate that wow you uh
you've been here for a while i
appreciate the support
uh
i'm hoping they come in like two years
because
we know basically the next two years
but uh yeah so all right
um
we're gonna watch ms marvel because
they're not uh
they're they're not miss marvel's
shorter by just like a tiny bit
uh let me get up this stop
watch is that what i do normally yeah
stop watch um we're gonna
move this to a new window so i can watch
it
and miss marvel it is the poll even
though it's a barely won but it's gonna
be miss marvel
we're gonna watch that first oh i'm in
star wars no wonder i can't find it
uh yes jonathan i i love the kenobi
series we are going to watch the finale
tonight but we're going to watch miss
marvel episode 3 right now destined mr
anderson we are going to be starting
five four
three
two
one
oh you know what
oh i got a new computer and i have new
stream labs so i don't
have i don't have
oh yeah no let's do the other screen
there it is
wait no
what did i do
oh i'm all messed up
there it is
i can't i can't hear it
that's not good
open volume mixer
she didn't try to kill me she saved my
life
[Music]
get in
i've been waiting a very long time to
meet you i'd like you to be my mom
[Music]
let's see what's going on
[Music]
i really like this uh his new intro
music here
[Music]
yeah hey jake what's going on
british occupied india
oh we're getting a little bit of the
backstory here is the sound is the sound
good now is the sound off i turned it
off right
is it off now sounds off right
okay cool cool jackhead says there we go
okay it's fine cool cool cool yeah
oh that's is that no that's not her
is it her
it's really dark
oh it's blue
it's a cree
right
that's got to be her great grandmother
she just said she said we would find two
that's one
is there two
dude are they really the mega bands
that
yes dude
twice
dude okay that guy oh oh oh did you see
that
the 10 rings
that's what that was right
dude that was a cree that was a cree all
day
nice
okay so she's not bad
um
another dimension
huh
hmm
okay but they're evil
yeah that was the 10 rings right am i
was i
mistaken i look like the 10 rings
what's up jimmy
i have newer
she's trying to find out her name
my cat she's like
11 years old
i think that was the ten rings
i really think it was ten more
you've inherited greatness there we go
gin
i am going to the thor premiere that is
thursday
i'm a chin
and tonic that's funny
jyn is like not an angel
but like
below an angel
hahaha
bruno
uh
yeah all the indian
watchers if you know what that is could
you explain jin
i thought it was like a being that like
wasn't as high as like an angel
but like
interdimensional travel
what's up sam clares
dr selvig
look at his room
uh it's pakistani
dude it's like a ghost interesting
woof
she got elected
oh no she didn't
hmm
oof
got him
got him
oh got him
i mean you can't just walk in and not be
respectful it's a religious building
even if you're not their religion you
should be perspective or irrespective i
just read perspective there
is she watching herself is that what
she's doing
yep she's watching herself i figured
that's funny
i don't
think it's chris's last movie jimmy
is she gonna tell the kia here
for knock knock here
oh she's not going to tell her now
we are watching miss marvel right now
oh she got elected
nice
dude bruh
bro
she is marcus
so i wonder if like
all of her
family
i wonder if all her family is gonna know
i'm nightlight
say it just like deadpool i'm batman
sana sana is my favorite member from
twice
oh
she's not trouble she just sticks out at
night
oh look at her just getting fed
nice
oh that's funny
hmm
you're her mother you should be ashamed
okay
so that guy's arm was blue and there
were two bands so they are totally the
mega bands
what's in the box bruno we don't talk
about bruno
hmm
this thing you do
called it
that's interesting
what's in the box
a note of his uh confessing his undying
love for her
oh cool
very cool oh so bruno uh
bruno designs her costume that's
actually kind of cool
old man wisdom
oh my gosh is she gonna stop a robbery
just like in the comics
syntheticness that's pretty funny
oh bruno's keeping all the secrets
all right we're about to learn something
here
ah demons
interesting
huh
so they were banned
primordial power
huh
of the sun
wow kamala
why can't you be the superhero
just train more
oh he told her he got the cow tact
oof
get it bruno
hmm
carol james would be reckless
oh
in the comics she her shape-shifting
powers give her
um
she has ability to heal
um
i don't know how to pronounce your name
that's how every single watch party on
youtube is man no one can show anything
but we all still do it
hmm
hmm
oh she found family
dom toretto would be proud
i don't know about that eric gord i
don't know why not
marcus johnson carol davidson karen
that's funny
tell your mother
tell your mother
come on i want you to tell people
tva
cheered up baby cheered up baby
pat
who would have thought that would happen
that's funny he seems like a cool dude
oh here we go who's texting
i'm assuming
comrade you sly dog go away she needs to
get with bruno
amir and tysha's wedding
yeah i know right marcus
ah that's the parent relationship though
right you know what i mean
i don't want to say it's love hate
because it's not like hate but it's like
you know go through
the good stuff and the bad stuff
oh
that's all he has
and 32
he's nervous about getting married
huh
oh she's gonna listen
i like this speech
now you gotta tell your family girl
interesting how they asked him three
times
uh black bear would you go with miss
marvel first we all went with miss
marvel first that's what we're doing
right now
26 minutes into miss marvel
oh she has your phone
i don't mean to insult this woman but
she just
kind of looks evil
oh
yeah and there it is
dumb would be proud marcus oh snap look
at this place that's a nice wedding
dang
huh
that's good damien
oh snap
some bollywood dancing stuff is kingo
gonna show up
oh that's fun
it's fun that the parents are doing that
hey her parents know it too that's
pretty cool
oh and her brother oh
i guess that's her brother
oh he's wearing the
the hulk the little hulk costume that
she did
there's kamala
she's gonna fall
that seems like fun
is that is that bruno
oh bruno
i'm white but that's that's that's
really that's white dancing right there
that's some dancing bruno
oh no
what's up ricky
good job bruno takes courage to do that
bollywood
well dang that's a fun time i actually
like this scene a lot
i know marcus where the heck is kingo i
mean not
brown jovi that's
uh oh
oh okay come run go away no go away no
dang
comrade is actually good
it's bruno
oh
i mean come on move away from move move
away from the fire alarm
oh it's bon jovi
you gotta grab the money
yo i'm loving this bon jovi though
that's kind of rude
wow i love this song
all right come on
we'll take the chef's knifes and stuff
that was rude
gotta hold oh
time to fight kamala
oh
we're halfway there
oh squidward on a chair
isn't not the meme
oh
bruh put the money up
huh
i feel like she can take you all on if
she just uses the powers
yeah red dagger isn't come run
she knows something's up
no they just did mass gamer they're just
wondering where she is
puncher uppercut uppercut
uppercut oh i just want to see you knock
someone out with a giant hand
what is in her hair
well i feel like people are gonna know
she's
what do they call it night light if
kamala's gone and then all of a sudden
night light comes out everyone's gonna
know that she's night light
oh what did he just pull out
and she's got a frying pan
what does happen oh it's covering her
was that is that a belt sword
no the cake
it's not a belt sword it's just a belt
oh my gosh please use the bengal to
fight and not just
what was that guy trying to accomplish
there you go
use the bengal to fight and stop just
defending
i don't know it's like a belt who threw
that bruno yeah bruno
what is this guy
using
yes finally thank you
oh she likes bruno oh nice i like that
like a pocket watch what is that
dude what is this magical belt thing
that he has
mr anderson delete anything about kenobi
please
use your freaking powers
is that comrade oh no
oh no
he was trying to be good
so
oh i thought red dagger was about to
show up somewhere
oh train whistle bro blowing
oh snap the dodc
i hate this woman i hate this girl i
mean granted she showed up at a pretty
good time but
no no one saw them no one saw them also
are these guys like ghosts can't they
like
about time
are you okay no i'm not
please tell them
i really i really want them
i really want her to tell them
i feel like you should tell them
i get you don't want to put them in
danger but
i feel like you should tell them
i hope they find out sometime at least i
mean jeez
all right see who it was nani
her grandmother
oh
i knew they would go to karachi i knew
it i said it in my last episode or my
last breakdown
this is yet that's the end of the
episode
all right
i don't see a post credit
is there a post credit
i don't see a post credit
what's going on
my disney plus screwed up
okay well uh
i quite enjoyed this episode actually
hi rocket what you doing
hi
silly cat
silly kitty i
quite enjoyed that episode not gonna lie
what do you guys think what everybody
think what's up jillian gomez
yeah i didn't see any post credits i i
kind of like that episode um i could use
more
of her powers i would really like her to
use more of her powers
no captain omega uh
i don't think they're i really don't
think they're doing the
the inhuman
storyline i really don't think that's
that's what they're doing
uh
yeah all right i don't want uh i don't
want to
[Music]
i don't want any kenobi spoilers so did
we just jump into it let's we could talk
about miss marvel for like a few minutes
um
i like this episode of miss marvel i
think
i i think it might i think that was my
favorite episode so far
uh
yeah see it was definitely better than
the last one definitely better than the
last one i don't know if i like the
first one better than it
uh
yeah i don't i don't know but that was a
good episode that was uh
that was good that was good that was
good um
i liked the wedding a lot
um
i like that nakia stood up
in the mosque a lot too
i don't know why i really liked that
scene i really like that scene and uh
i want her to tell her parents man
okay wait hold on i gotta i gotta check
something out
because in the beginning
hold on
okay so in the beginning that's a blue
hand okay so cree
uh the that's a cree hand
and was that the ten rings that is my
question
where do they show it
i thought we saw where okay what did
they show us the relics i'm trying to
find it
so this is of course how it's all going
to tie into
captain marv the marvel's captain marvel
2.
the british have looted it
there
that's the ten rings
wow okay so this is all gonna be way
more connected than we thought it was
wow so the 10 rings
yo could the mandarin have had
this weapon at one point in time
oh wow cause clearly this was hidden
by the ten rings
oh
wow i think that yeah
so
could the
could the 10 rings be cree
i think the 10 rings are cree technology
oh
dude
i that makes perfect sense because
they're you know it's alien technology
and granted they're changing mcu origins
or
marvel comic origins a lot
but dang okay so
yeah i think the i think the
the ten rings are cree tech wow
dude oh that's so i okay
and and kevin feige just said like
yesterday that everything's gonna make
sense a little bit more wow look at how
everything's being connected
oh that's so cool that's so cool that's
so cool okay yeah um
that's pretty cool that's i think that's
i think that's pretty cool and yeah i
think the dodc is scrolls i'm with you
on that mr anderson
gosh that's so cool okay so it's all
gonna be connected
but now i'm now i'm like
i wanna know the backstory behind the
ten rings hiding this bangle and i wanna
know who has the other one
who would have the now they did say
the british were uh where's the other
one
the british have probably looted this
place twice by now twice
um
uh
anime dimension but captain marvel said
ten rings is not cree tech
that's true maybe that she maybe that
she knows of
huh interesting interesting oh
well it's connected somehow
maybe the cree used it
maybe they didn't create it but maybe
the crew used it
this is going to be big i feel like this
is going to be
i feel like this is going to be really
really big so uh sean
we're we're looking at the 10 rings in
the beginning of miss marvel
it clearly shows the 10 rings
around
around the bengal
no we watched miss marvel first nate the
snake
i think it's crete tech i i
i really do think it's creepy it just
makes sense
or scroll tech i mean you know what i
mean like
because they've been at war with each
other and all that stuff yeah that's the
tin rings like
look at that that's really cool it's
really cool how they're connecting all
this
aj are you still there
aj
he's muted he's in my discord
yeah all right i i want to stop i want
to start with kenobi before it gets
spoiled i do have to use the bathroom
no take me to star wars
maybe i don't know if the mandarin had
the other bengal maybe
maybe it made the tin ring somehow
i don't know i gotta i gotta think about
that
[Music]
i gotta think about that all right let
me use the bathroom um
let me use the bathroom and then we're
gonna watch the kenobi finale
part six brb
rocket
say hi rocket
say hi rocket
i'm trying i'm trying there you go say
hi hi what's up
oh sorry
[Music]
say hi say hi you fat cat she's so fat
what
what
[Music]
you're okay
she she always whines like that
she whines a lot all right let's uh
i hope rocket doesn't have tentacles
like goose that'd be terrifying
okay let's uh
let's start kenobi where is everything
all right
five
four
three
two
one boom
stork kenobi time
now she wants to get out hold on
[Music]
i won't skip the recap just to root just
to keep the timing kind of the same
we'll stick to the same
all right
let's do this
kenobi kenobi kenobi
you're hunting him
let's turn this volume up a little bit
there we go
yeah i'm hoping for qui-gon too kevin
um i actually don't know how to turn the
chat off or i would
let's just let's just i i'm go i'm gonna
i'm gonna oh crap oops
i'm gonna avoid chat um
till after i don't want uh i don't want
spoilers guys
so uh if you want to avoid the chat too
until after you watch the episode i i
understand we can talk about it after
because uh i mean this is it in the
finale here we go
yeah i was so sad tala died
i didn't understand the ending
i didn't understand the ending
i really didn't
okay so let's do this i'm gonna i'm
gonna kind of get away from the the chat
for a little bit guys i love you all
still
but uh
i don't want obi-wan spoilers
so let's do this
mr anderson's gonna be on you guys
where can't i hear it
that's why my headset was turned on
oh that's rude oh that's the guy that
kenobi used to work for right
oh she's still alive
oh
oh what's happening here
vader
i just can't believe we have vader again
like look how awesome this is i mean
so good
come on king go help him out
you gotta make a move obi-wan
we have a jedi master granted a
out of shape one but
but you have one use them come on come
on we need you to force stop all of this
well kenobi and leia are in episode four
so i'm thinking they live
huh
i'm sorry oh no
dang
where is the future
come on hajja
[Laughter]
what of a liar in a fake
chat say it say the may the force be
with you ah give us your chance okay go
it's okay you guys don't die yet you get
burned alive later well not maybe not
not really burned alive but
turn to the skeleton eventually
but she she's already inside
have no chance
well okay
oh
guns okay
well we know they don't die now
which is kind of interesting to watch
this stuff knowing like okay well these
people aren't gonna die but i just said
that tala died
hmm
oh i said talas
oh there's talas
oh with the notches and everything dang
i wasn't gonna give you a blaster
day
come back
nice
oh my gosh that was so uh
thank you jake for the super chat holy
crap oh my gosh that was so
loud oh oh call upon your master qui-gon
come back right now i want to see it yes
okay okay okay here we go talk to him
oh i just want to see quite gone or hear
him
hmm
okay ice cube son
please give me quack on now
nope
maybe at the end
kind of how obi-wan and yoda and
vader appear to luke
it's him
nope
oh
please kill him
please kill him
that's [ __ ] obi-wan kenobi
i wish you would say that i wish the
meme
of course
ah i wish we had more flashbacks i
really love the flashback
that we got last episode
look at that tiny little ship
i thought you were supposed to get into
position already y'all are slow
it's okay i can confirm that you three
live
you're doing great ben
whooshes is what the captions say
i wonder what planet that is
oh
hmm
[Music]
sorry for everybody watching i i'm not
watching the chat so i don't have it
spoiled but i will return after this
episode
oh he has lula
tell me there's a message for him
just like
she does with r2d2
oh
all right kenobi
it's a little too bright in here i can't
i'm gonna turn on the lights a little
bit because i can't see very well
even though they're turned down pretty
low
there's a ship
those little red oh
yeah
let's do this
i'm he just gonna run right at him
what's the deal
it's gonna be some dialogue i'm sure
there we go
i will do what i must love it
everyone's going for it too
oh
he's going for it he's going for the
kill
this is so epic
he's pointing it right at him
no she'll be worth a fight
oh that's that back
hi kyrie
no one's seen you
come here
no one's seen you oh
everybody's seen rocket
this is kyrie i got rachel what you
doing
what you doing say hi
say hi to everybody
okay i i really hope this gets explained
not that strong in the force are you
oh they've like really moved into like
the terrain like
now
oh
let's see some four stuff
this is so cool
obi-wan
rolls a lot
fights you know
yeah
oh
use that force oh
your strength has returned
it's still there oh
nice
oh
oh
well balls
collapsing the freaking ground oh
he's gonna straight up bury him
okay
i'm is gonna burst burst out like
superman
oh gosh
oh uncle low
oh
she could
justice
oh she wants to kill him because his
vader's son i get it
yeah i was gonna
oh
oh
luke's probably like you said tuscan
raiders there's a freaking sith
coming at me
red lightsaber bruh
all right obi jump out like you're
superman
isn't now is quite gone gonna talk to
him
okay so none of it's falling on me okay
okay okay
oh he's thinking of little leia that's
going to give him the strength
and lu oh he's taking a look too of
course
do it
we're on adam
looks like he's floating
yeah you know vader
fight
oh i like the hand switch
oh yes finally using some force yeah get
a movie
oh snap
we're seeing who the master is
vader you have a lightsaber in your hand
and you're blocking rocks with your arm
that's pretty dang cool
he's still darth vader
that's so epic
oh that's so epic
oh maybe they used to tuscan raiders to
hunt her
i wonder if he's going to cut off
another limb
oh
oh he's cutting off oh
[Music]
he's of course doesn't kill him because
he feels
still his padawan
oh
gonna go i hate you
oh
[Music]
dang
oh yeah it's gonna be hard to look at
oh he caught a mannequin
dang
oh ho ho i love the half voice
oh look how sad he is
i feel for you obi-wan
dad
wow
wow
i did
oh they're red
you're not in the position to be making
threats vader
you were my brother
i loved you
i just called him darth
i love that
oh
dang
that's like
your old mess just defeated you and
didn't even like
kill you
it just left you there
so he could haunt you jeez
sorry
that's pretty good
all right tuscan raiders where you at
woof
oh is he gonna show up to save the day
oh dang
you going to go vader you're going to
kill a youngling
we never found out how her saber got put
back together did we
oh
she sees herself
exactly you'd be just like anakin
you'd be just like lord vader
obviously you can't do it woman become
what you hate
you just need to send some obi-wan
they're calling his name you think they
know where he is
oof
he's obviously not dead
they think he's dead
he's alive
what if like owen just pulls out a gun
shoots her in the face
are they gonna fight now
where did you fail
hmm
you've chosen not to
hmm
hmm
a lot of lightsabers get buried on that
planet and that does it there huh
what's the pod
so now what oh we're gonna see palpatine
hello palpatine
i've left you weakened
palpatine imperial march
[Music]
oh i love this freaking
this song hits
all right now go talk to leia yep knew
that was coming
that's a fancy city
look at her little gloves
oh she's gonna put taller oh
that's cute
and she's there not ran away into the
woods
is that a holster
i just thought in my mind like
they don't look like their mother and
daughter but they're actually
not
that is uh
anakin and padme's daughter
it's obi-wan
it's all the one yeah
oh
and lola
more excited for lola
that's very loud wow
thank you for that super chat
agreeing guruji
thank you very much
a fancy city you got there
i'll watch after your brother
you should sleep
something about her mom
just like your mother
they came from your father
dang
that's intense
dang
oh because she has her own parents now
a little bit
no
with the hugs
and with you
oh the good old force theme
i'm tired
oh she puts lola in her holster and
that's cute
that's cute
what's in there
hmm he's leaving
goodbye cave
um
up
oh and you're kind of a douche and
i'm not sad you die there i said it
i'm gonna see your skeleton one day
he's never met him
all right
oh i was gonna give him the toy
he said it
oh
he said hello there oh perfect
i'm so happy
so happy
oh i'm so happy hello there
oh
no
are we is it qui god
it's qui-god
master qui-gon
neeson
yes
oh that's awesome oh that's so great
i'm so happy
dang
all right is there a post credit
is there a post credit does anybody know
no ob one will return
wow
okay um he said hello there and i saw
qui-gon and i'm a happy man
i'm
i'm happy wow
wow
i'm getting teary-eyed oh
i really am getting teary-eyed um
that was pretty epic
oh
that was pretty awesome um
i love star wars i know i talked about
marvel a lot of time but i love star
wars
and uh
yeah that was the hello there and then
qui-gon showing up and i i like how he
left vader i like how he defeated him
but didn't kill him
and he said sorry
i like how he like kind of insulted him
and he was like by darth like he didn't
even say
uh
by darth vader
like he he just said by darth
so uh
wow i love that um
as a whole
as as a series
i really like this series um
this is one of my favorite disney this
is
this is i think this was better than
mando season one and two
and that's hard to say because there's a
lot of really great
really really great episodes of amanda
in season 1 and season 2 but um
oh that was pretty good that was pretty
pretty good so i wonder what happens to
riva now i i
i bet we're gonna
i bet we're gonna get some type of a
spin-off about her right
i bet you
i i bet you we get some type of spin-off
about her um
hmm
and we got uh yeah yeah nate this thing
we got palpatine
um
yeah
palpatine vader's helmet cut where you
saw anakin
and kenobi kind of got like that little
uh
what did they say uh what was it um he
got to like this little uh
like self-relief
when vader was like
vader's not
right anakin's wasn't your failure you
know whatever he said you know i i
killed anarchy you know vader killed
anakin um
yeah like i
was pretty cool
a lot of
i feel like a lot paid off i feel like
yeah i feel like a lot paid off
so
i'm happy and that ending made me really
happy oh man i really loved the fight i
really loved all the force that was
being used that scene where kenobi is
just like sitting there like this and
everything uh
going away and then like cuts vader's
mask off and vader's just like defeated
and he's yelling kenobi
and uh
meets luke
that's super awesome gives him uh
gives him his toy finally of his uh
t16
um
dang uh then hello there i
uh
yeah nate this thing there there was so
yeah i i
yeah there was so much stuff you know
now d rabbit white i i got you man i did
yeah it was mcgregor yeah tyler
uh yeah i believe
that is to be true as well brock goose
thompson yeah just the whole low there
it's so funny because that's something i
wanted and i completely spaced it i was
like so in this episode i was so in this
episode
and
yeah i i love it i love it um when he
said hello there i was so happy jillian
i like yeah no totally um
yeah
when when
obi-wan tells luke you know darth vader
killed his father 100 accurate because
you know that i love how they tied that
in there at the end you know vader
saying i killed anakin
you know uh
yeah chas wasn't that so cool i thought
that was so cool how it was half
anakin's voice in half darth vader's
voice
that was that was really cool yeah nate
right it's pretty it's pretty uh it's
pretty terrifying yeah that was uh oh
that was pretty dang good that was a
that was a great finale in all honesty
that was a
oh it was a great finale yeah i i want i
want more
now i want uh
i want another i want obi-wan season two
kenobi season two
it'd be cool if they had a uh darth
vader show
right that'd be really cool uh we need
like live action and i guess we kind of
are getting
you know live-action clone wars and and
rebels and
i'd like to i'd like them to really
explore
that live action you know
yeah
leia was awesome um
yeah this this this was a great episode
i really i think they
i think they nailed it i really i really
do think they nailed this um
yeah it went right d rabbit it was a
better it was
i feel like it was that final taunt when
he was just like
by vader
not
or by darth not not darth vader
just it was kind of like that just final
little jab like i just defeated you and
now i'm just gonna be like by darth like
it's almost like peter parker see a
chump like that's what i felt like it
was i felt like it was see a chump
that's really uh
that's what i thought it was that's what
i feel like it was
um
dang
well i really like that and i
this episode of miss marvel is really
good too
so
overall good night and i'm really tired
and i got work to do
and i fly to la tomorrow so
you know
is what it is
yeah so that was really good
well
oh yeah that would be really cool at
chris
if uh
if darth maul
appeared yeah i was kind of getting
concerned there that uh
that qui-gon wasn't gonna appear i was
really getting us concerned i was like
why would you
why would you tease that if you weren't
going to give us that you know what i
mean so that was given to us i'm happy
um
yeah i i am
good at my dog oh good i am going to
sleep now uh and then
then i'm gonna do work when i wake up i
gotta get a little bit of sleep i'm
really really tired um
yeah chris that would have been funny if
when if darth vader said something about
having the high ground
but i'm so glad he said hello there i
that was so good that was so good i we
got it
that's what we wanted and we got it
uh
so yeah so yeah that was great ending i
loved it um
i want more i want more like this from
star wars i uh
i want more like this it'd be really
really
cool
so we're gonna call tonight uh mr
anderson has started a channel as well
he is my mod uh if you guys want to show
him some support he just put his link to
his channel in the uh in the chat right
there
um
and if you're not following me and you
want to subscribe feel free to go ahead
and do that um
a lot of star wars stuff coming up soon
that i'm hoping to do watch parties for
and and cover although the the two uh
two different series on one night is uh
is uh
it's kind of
taken its toll on me so we'll have to
we'll have to see but uh
but yeah so um
thank you everybody for stopping by um
appreciate you all
appreciate all the super chats the
regular chats and people who are just
watching in the background as always you
are very much appreciated
and now it's time for me to get some
sleep and get some work and then fly to
la and then attend the thor level
thunder premiere so um
look out for
my
my reaction friday morning because we
can't really do an official review
until like right before
um
yeah so
friday morning will be like a reaction
to where you can kind of gauge how i
feel about the
about the uh
about the ship
hello okay my mic shot my wireless mic
uh
uh
battery dead
it wasn't plugged in so okay i'm going
to see you all
next tuesday uh for miss marvel episode
four
i'm sad kenobi's over but this was a
great finale so uh look out for my thor
reaction friday morning look out for
some cool videos tomorrow and thursday
and uh again thank you to everybody i
appreciate you all love you all 3 000.
wait no i'm stopping saying that and now
i'm saying i love you in every universe
that's what i'm saying now because i
really like that line from multiverse of
madness so love you on every universe
and i will see you all next time mr
anderson thank you for being a great mod